some 13.8 billion years ago a very hot
small and dense singularity expanded
into what we now call the universe it
hasn't stopped growing since but what if
it did what if all the galaxies stars
planets everything stopped moving away
from everything else with the universe
as it is just freeze or would it
collapse into a single point just like
it was before the Big Bang and would
that be the end of everything this is
what if and here's what would happen if
the universe stopped expanding before
the 1920s when Edwin Hubble observed
that the galaxies moved away from each
other
we thought the universe was static years
later the Hubble Space Telescope showed
us that not only is the universe
expanding but it's growing at an
ever-increasing rate this came as a
total surprise for astrophysicists they
expected that the expansion was actually
slowing down due to the force of gravity
to explain the discovery they theorized
that there's a force speeding up the
expansion of the universe they called it
dark energy what if this hypothesized
energy suddenly stopped pulling the
universe apart let's assume the strength
of dark energy diminished over time but
was still enough to counteract the force
of gravity what would that look like if
that were the case the universe would
become just like Albert Einstein
imagined it 100 years ago before
Hubble's discovery changed the game and
Einsteins viewpoint it would be static
the universe would neither be expanding
nor contracting eventually stars would
exhaust all the gas needed for their
formation fewer new stars would be born
existing ones would burn out the
universe would grow darker packed with
black holes by that time the earth would
be long gone
absorbed by a red giant star that used
to be our Sun at some point it would
reach its eventual temperature minimum
absolute zero or zero K on the Celsius
side that's minus 273 degrees at that
temperature atoms themselves would stop
moving the universe would become
absolutely lifeless but let's go back
and assume that dark energy became so
weak that it couldn't counteract the
force of gravity anymore once the
gravity took over it would pull
everything back the universe would start
contracting galaxies would draw closer
together until they merge into one mega
galaxy with the Stars melding into each
other space would become hotter than the
Sun and again packed with black holes
the result of exploding stars these
black holes would suck up everything
around them planets stars entire
galaxies even one another eventually
they'd form one monstrous black hole
that would pull the entire universe into
a single point hot small and extremely
dense
the universe would end in a big crunch
reverting back into what I looked like
at the start and who knows the
newly-formed singularity might explode
into another Big Bang creating a brand
new universe with new stars new planets
and new life-forms we don't know exactly
how our universe blend we don't even
understand what the dark energy pulling
it apart is that's why there's not just
one theory explaining the ultimate fate
of the universe there are several good
ones any one of them might be correct
but they could be wrong altogether
join us next time on what if
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]